we've only seen drake's three-year-old
son a few times on his social media
but on sunday drake brought adonis out
on stage with him as he was recognized
as the artist of the decade
at the billboard music awards
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
hey hey
um thank you very much very very very
much
to my beautiful family and hey wait wait
and to you i want to dedicate this
towards me
oh my goodness i was at the the after
party that they threw
and it was uh it was incredible it was
very emotional it was a huge event they
had it at sophie stadium
and um basically yeah all the friends
and family were there for the most part
they had dinner on the 50-yard line they
had fireworks
and honestly just the whole night is
just incredible it's truly an
accumulation of hard work
and i can't think of anybody more
deserving
you know in this industry especially you
know as long as we've been in this
industry for
you know there's always the fear of the
drop and you're always legacy building
and that's one thing about him
is just that doesn't matter how many
wins that he has
he's always thinking of the next thing
and how to make
honest real music every single day and
um
yeah the whole event was just super
emotional because at least for me
obviously you know
you know we've known each other me and
aubry since like 14 15 years old
and i've seen the zero one two three
four all the way up to the ten and
everyone sees the ten and sees the end
result
but this is such a an accumulation of
just hard work and sacrifice and
resilience and
so many doors closed that he had to
break open and find a new way
so this was just like an incredible
moment because it's like yes
this is he is the goat he truly is
there's nobody doing what he's doing
and he deserves all the love and all the
praise him bringing out his son was just
so special his son is adorable
first of all um but you know there's so
many loud noises
he's just a kid you know but it's cool
for him to see his dad
having this glorious moment and for
aubry just just to
bring his kid and be like look look what
your daddy did
it's inspirational he's inspirational
the whole team is inspirational so yeah
this was
this was really cool those moments with
your kid are
incredible what did they serve what did
they serve what was the food
what was the food the biggest thing was
chicken
there was some really good chicken i'm
not even gonna lie to you like what
like like what kind of chicken like
fried chicken or like roasted chicken
yeah
it was a fried chicken i forget the name
and i feel so bad because it was
branded everywhere but it was some bomb
chicken the music was incredible
um his friends always dj the events uh
mark and noel shout out to them
so they did a really good job and um his
friend
angelo actually threw this party
like ovoh wouldn't put it together but
like his friend
did this and this is one of the most
most magical parties i've ever been to
in my life it was so well put together
um and very iconic yeah i was like
how do you throw a party yeah i was like
how do you how do you throw a party and
still manage to get people to social
distance well you rent a football
stadium
right which there are there are very few
people in the world
who could and would rent a football
stadium for a party
drake's one of them yes and he deserves
it
yes yes yes oh my goodness all right
indigo says what a cutie pie such a
sweet dad moment for drake
uh linda says loved it thought it was
very uh sweet um
indigo says it was cubic clearly a lot
uh for his son
um yeah like he said what were we
thoughts and him brings bring out his
son on stage like that's a huge thing to
do like obviously drake's
kept the donuts pretty much out of the
public life but maybe like three or four
posts he's done on the social media over
three years so
this is huge to bring him out on stage
yeah it's super huge and
honestly the entire all the guys were on
the stage you know so it was still
somewhat comfortable for his son it
wasn't like he was going out with just
drake and
they're on stage and there's all these
people screaming and he is you know
there were people on the stage that
would make him feel comfortable that are
family to him
but such a huge gesture you know he is
super private and um to bring his son
it just made it more magical his mom and
dad were there as well
it was fitting it was fitting to bring
him and he's just so cute
what a great moment
yeah it's it's i always love the moment
where you see
somebody you know who you never thought
would sort of slide perfectly into that
role
and when i see drake posting pictures of
his kid i'm always reminded of
colin farrell who colin farrell for
years had the reputation of being
hollywood's drunkest rowdiest frat boy
bad boy everything and when colin
farrell had a kid
colin farrell became a different human
being and when i look at drake i'm like
i love to see those moments
where it is this sort of metamorphosis
of this perfect person we've seen
drake's change
so many times over the years and you
know this change
is so incredible because it's it's a
personal change it's one that we were
not able to see
until he decided to show it to us you
know on the on
the stage over the weekend and just
watching him even the way his kid ran
away from him
you know that has happened a million
times and he said reach back and grab
that little arm
and be like not so fast little man i
love those moments i think it's great
i think it's it's incredible that they
got to share that together